retrouve internet de l'école jusqu'aux
grandes surfaces voyez ce reportage de
maryse mano avec michel viano latos
c'est immuable tous les mercredis à
parthenay des lots de bestiaux
s'achètent et se vendent selon des rites
séculaire honte aux plats
du commerce électronique
ils ne connaissent rien et rien du tout
pour moi
car elle a jeté les bases moins chère
madame
et puis il ya ceux qui sont perméables à
la modernité
des morts
avancé
ça permet à tout le monde de profiter de
deux de ses réseaux au niveau des gens
de parthenay je trouve que c'est très
bien
déjà partenaire se visite sur internet
une vitrine accessible au monde entier
dans cette cité médiévale 10% de la
population
cliquer sur son ordinateur les autres
peuvent utiliser ceux de la ville pour
tous renseignements il suffit de cliquer
les services de la mairie les activités
scolaires la tête des enseignants mais
aussi l'envoi d'un cv aux entreprises
qui embauchent enfin depuis peu
appartenait on peut faire ses courses
sans bouger de chez soi
une fois par semaine la famille passa
commande au centre commercial du centre
ville elle choisit parmi les 7500
produits répertoriés pour un montant
minimal obligatoire d'au moins 300
francs
mois en clair c'était c'était une heure
et demie deux heures pour aller faire ce
que je suis ici en 15 minutes quoi donc
forcément il fait beaucoup d'activités
voilà beaucoup d'activités enfin ils
font plus d'activités sportives et
cetera donc c'est vrai qu'ils ont la
sensation maintenant que j'ai plus ce
temps j'ai plus de temps à leur
consacrer comme
la commande n'est pas anonyme sur le
site la photo de robert qui viendra
livrer tout à l'heure c'est lui qui
relève les commandes au magasin bonjour
bâtiment on appellera bien c'est sa
formule tout le monde me connaît par
robert
liste en main si robert qui va remplir
le caddie tout ce qui est lourd les
packs de lait d'eau minérale c'est pour
lui on voit bien l'intérêt pour le
client le magasin en revanche ne peut
plus compter sur l'achat coup de coeur
l'ordinateur ne cède pas à la tentation
visuel mais comme le client est
contraint à la fidélité le panier ne
désemplit pas c'est certainement pour
eux des économies mais nous on constate
que la moyenne panier est intéressante
aussi intéressante que pour des clients
qui viennent régulièrement dans le
magasin donc pas de souci de ce côté là
vous vous dites pas en jouer à
l'apprenti sorcier ah non non non je
m'entends pour associer n'ont pu
je pense pas on expérimente un nouveau
style de commerce et puis est ce que ce
sera le commerce de l'or 2000 je n'en
sais rien
l'expérience touche pour l'instant trois
pour cent de la clientèle du supermarché
des femmes actives pour l'essentiel qui
acceptent de payer le service 30 francs
de plus si elles viennent chercher le
caddie au magasin 60 francs si elles se
font livrer à la maison seuls les
enfants ne trouvent plus tout à fait
leurs comptes
et vous les enfants vous aimiez paléo
aller au supermarché avec maman ainsi
c'était bien
tout ça mais ça se finit alors avec ce
système